rabia e indignación en nueva delhi con
gritos y pancartas decenas de mujeres
denunciaron la protección de violadores
y la penalización de las víctimas por
parte del estado una protesta por la
reciente decisión de la gobernación de
gujarat luego de la liberación de 11
hombres condenados en 2008 a cadena
perpetua decisión tomada en el marco de
la celebración por los 75 años de la
independencia del imperio británico en
la que también critican el silencio del
gobierno central del populista hindú y
narendra modi este medio donde creen que
cuando vemos que el gobierno usa
políticas de remisión para liberar a los
condenados por violación ya los asesinos
en masa antes de que cumplan su tiempo
completo en prisión las voces que
defienden la justicia se ponen ansiosas
esto demuestra que en el entorno actual
no estamos logrando ningún progreso
estamos retrocediendo a los 11 hombres
violaron en grupo a una mujer musulmana
en embarazo y asesinaron a su hija de 3
años en medio del conflicto hindú
musulmán que inundó de violencia al
estado de gujarat en 2002 causando más
de 1000 muertos
la violencia religiosa es frecuente en
la india desde su nacimiento como estado
actualmente bajo el mandato de modi
perteneciente al partido popular indio
la tensión entre hindúes y musulmanes ha
aumentado por lo que las manifestantes
ven la liberación de estos hombres una
forma de politización de la justicia
igual primer se está liberando a
asesinos y a violadores en india y el
gobierno del partido popular indio del
señor modi así como a mí ya ministro del
interior los apoyan esto es totalmente
inaceptable en la india independiente o
men las mujeres exigen que el ministro
del interior se pronuncie y revoque la
decisión